gonna go into that because i have a lot
to say about that question but uh after
this match hopefully fgl
versus os honey guys we're getting
locked and loaded this guy fgl i have
not heard of him before today but he has
impressed me impressed me with his
matches against uh ferzine and now he's
versus a waste honey here guys top eight
action loser side
it's gonna be a big test for both
players of course as we go into this we
are in the open stage here
arctic snowfall a spot of tea in the
middle of the snow fight
all right let's go
all right starting it off
nice big boot starting it off with the
root of evil follow up here
why sunny already trying to get a feel
here but a nice flip over
fgl able to capitalize and get some
damage
nice
okay big damage playing
great here in this opening round
yeah oh my god dude
all right okay
fgl really kind of showed off his
expertise in this particular matchup and
his comfort going up against akuma but
you know this is not just any akuma this
is the best akuma player in the world
so right now this is gonna be a true
test of his knowledge of the matchup but
maybe even the knowledge of the player
there's no way that he does not know who
a wise honey is
okay
nice condom very important to use those
very important to use those homing moves
that's a lily she has the best sidewalk
in the game
oh yeah
and fdl knows it he was able to kind of
sidestep a lot of the things early on by
the way able to capitalize here
ends it with a very clean simple combo
there with the shocking nets fight
guys he's making sure his down position
works i see him i see him yeah yeah yeah
you got to make sure it works check the
arcade stick
all right there you go
this is how it starts this is bound to
happen always honey is never going to
make it easy oh my god that was a sick
call out in a sick read there he knew he
wasn't going for the tackle he he pops
off with his own power crush that was
crazy
nice left
he has rage if he touches him it's over
one touch is dead
oh my god what is that hey lily is uh
she's a 3d character that's crazy
that 100 is a 3d versus beauty if i ever
saw it have you got a down jab counter
hit into the launcher or where's honey
working on another barometer
he just he thought about it that time
he's like i'm not gonna go for the
shoulder tackle this time last night he
got launched for it
oh good luck
man but he's still wild enough to go for
the the dragon punch that's crazy but
man fgl is countering everything at
every instance almost
hey and finally always funny using the
homing move realizing fgl is doing a lot
of sidewalks and that's going to be
final round incoming
fight there we go
nice oh my god the punish of the
fireball sidestepping into down four
deepest four
this man knows the killer i told you
again this is the final round here in
this opening match a wise honey with the
life deficit will he be able to catch up
if you are looking really really good
here
hold the side steps
[Music]
honey he's no slash man fgl can compete
with the best of him right now taking it
to hawaii's honey v akuma of pakistan
the akuma of the world
and uh lily was you know just chilling
lily had it under control
yeah absolutely you see that that move
that the slide as well it's so active it
seems like you can with punish it you
seem like oh it's he's with it but it
stays active for so long as soon as you
press the button
it was counter hit and you managed to
kill with the combo and you guys saw i
mean i don't have to tell you anymore
that he's good versus akuma you saw the
sidewalks sidewalk left into duck
blocking the down threes uh side
stepping the down forward one twos
getting great punishes floating demon
flip everything is on point right now
this is exactly what we saw versus
brazilian and um that's why he put
frazil into losers
now he's looking to to to do uh the same
to awesome and take him out of the
tournament here
yeah it's been great stuff so far i mean
eye-opening you know kind of really
showing that his again his comfort in
the matchup
a weiss has an opportunity here he is
one match away from being eliminated
though but he has to make a tough
decision here is it going to be akuma do
you believe in the kuma all the way i
mean it was closer down to the last
round right
but there was definitely some
preparation
on fgl's side think about is he going to
switch over to negan that's the question
i
think
let's see let's see what he does here is
it going to be negan no akuma
now imagine this mark
fgl's if he is to win this match
his last two wins
were arslan ash
is that that's that's correct right you
haven't heard about this player from
today i haven't heard about it no this
player until today
but this guy is a beast man
fight a beast yeah and this is why i
love watching these tlcs man and why you
should all be tuning in every single
week here we go guys fgl can he take out
a waste honey
here we go
man he is all over the place
in the right spots where he needs to be
fgl looking so strong here has him at
the wall good pressure here nice punish
there from wise honey
oh god
had an opportunity there oh he tried to
punish he tried to yeah
oh rage drive can he finish the combo
keep this simple down two two three fgl
with all of the momentum right now oh
where's honey on the back foot
oh he canceled he had to put the punish
still
yo it's not looking good a weiss needs
to make these adjustments right away
what a duck
no punish he ducked the string
every time that fireball comes out he is
ready locked and loaded
fgl nice block nice block oh my god is
he gonna hit
give him a chance
oh my god
sidestep is so good
round three one round
but as soon as you say that he pops off
he gets the damage i'm using the meter
oh he stays he knows not to mess with it
and i'm punished ready to go trying to
take his turn back but a wise honey with
the life lead here let's see what he
does
nice block oh no oh my god
hey guys you guys are watching some
crazy [ __ ] oh my gosh
finally catch him here that was a nice
instant while standing two there
but he's kind of sealed away a lot of a
wise honey strength you know he can't
will he nearly throw out the fireball
anymore he has to be very aware but here
big opportunity
let me go he'll be able to get the wall
as well
he goes for damage
oh my god she almost got underneath it
oh yeah i thought that was going to hit
massive black people always honestly not
to take your final round
i almost bit my microphone
why is honey fighting for this
oh my god no
no reaction
nice oh my god what a duck buddy combo
you might be dead you might be getting
gl
that's gonna be it
takes out a waste honey two oh with a
comeback in that round beautiful stuff
always honey eliminated from tlc master
event south asia fgl his last two win